[Music]
what are your thoughts about playing
here in the city of Zagreb oh well it's
very interesting I've never been to
Croatia before and I don't I think it's
the first time that they've held the
high-level chess tournament and
especially one this strong because this
is strongest 11 round tournament that
has ever been held this is my first time
in Croatia and I really enjoyed
travelling around the country and the
capital is very beautiful so I'm very
excited every time I play in a big city
is always exciting very good environment
and I feel comfortable being here
I like sit most fear here and I know in
general the people here are very
receptive to chess I think we're gonna
have a very nice time I'm excited I
played in Croatia once before but there
was many years ago and I'm encouraged is
a traditional great chess country chess
has really loved here so it's great to
play in a place where young people
appreciate the games and people will
follow it closely and with what support
also the usual destination for a chess
player I don't recall playing here
before and and from what I've seen so
far the city is very lovely well it's my
first time in Zagreb just the city is
nice I have been walking yesterday and
today also and the food is nice the
hotel is nice so I'm looking forward for
the good tournament but I think it is
very nice idea with some tournaments in
new city it's my first time being in
Croatian quite a few years I've only
been to Croatia once before in 2011 when
I was training with Garry Kasparov in
general seems like a pretty nice City
I'm just looking forward to playing good
Chesser like Roshan very much and
probably one of my best tournaments in
my life European Championship in 2010
was held in Riga it's also Croatia
it looks wonderful so far the weather
the weather is great and the Sun is out
and ready to go